just like what we have seen in the
previous sessions we play with these
five digits and here's our question take
a moment and read it well using these
five digits
how many three-digit numbers greater
than 200 can be formed let's read it
again three-digit numbers greater than
200 and again we have two cases when
repetition is not allowed and when it's
allowed let's understand the first case
we have to form three-digit numbers so
we make three slots for each of the
digits read the question again do we
have a condition here yes the condition
is that the three-digit number must be
greater than 200 and we have seen before
that if we have a condition we always
start with it
it means we start with the hundredths
place this is a golden rule if you're
given a condition always start with it
now ask yourself one simple question if
the number has to be greater than 200
then in how many ways can the hundreds
place be filled don't forget we can use
only one of these five digits think it's
easy if the number has to be greater
than 200 then the hundredths place
should have a digit greater than two so
we can fill the hundreds place with a
three or a four or a five in three ways
correct this is a very common mistake
that students do it's incorrect the
hundredths place can be filled with a
two or a three or a four or a five
even 213 is greater than 200 245 is also
greater than 200 the only number that
will not be greater than 200 when 2 is
in the hundreds place is 200 but here
zero is not one of the five digits so we
don't have to worry about that special
case of 200 there are four ways in which
the hundredths place can be filled with
a 2 or a 3 or a 4 or of
five not a one as the number has to be
greater than 200 now we move on to the
next slot assuming we have filled the
hundreds place with one of these four
digits in how many ways can the tens
place be filled think carefully
one digit is used here in how many ways
can we fill the second slot as one digit
is gone four remain simple the second
slot can be filled in four ways if we
use a four here then one among one two
three and five can be used here if we
use a two here then one among one three
four and five can be used here so having
used one digit in the hundreds place the
tens place can be folded four ways now
having used up two digits for the
hundreds and the tens place in how many
ways can the unit's digit be filled as
two digits are used obviously three
would be left it can be filled in three
ways we are filling the first and the
second and the third slot so we multiply
these numbers the total number of ways
would be four times four times three it
equals forty eight ways and what is this
48 it is the number of different
three-digit numbers greater than 200
that can be formed using these five
digits but when repetition is not
allowed will the answer change if
repetition is allowed let's move to a
new page we try to answer the second
part here using these five digits
how many three-digit numbers greater
than 200 can be formed if repetition is
allowed we make three slots to represent
the three digits in how many ways can we
fill the hundreds place as the number
has to be greater than 200 we can fill
it with a two or a three or a four or a
five four ways okay good now answer this
question having used up one digit here
in how many ways can we fill the second
slot
so after having used up one digit here
does it mean that there are just four
ways in which you can fill up the slot
no it does not
repetition is allowed if we use a three
here we can use it again in the tens
place the number of ways in which the
tens and the unit's place can be filled
is independent of the condition as
repetition is allowed the second slot or
the tens place can be filled with any
one of the five digits we have it can be
filled in five ways and with the same
logic even the unit's place can be
folded five ways why four ways for the
first slot because we cannot fill it
with a one the number has to be greater
than 200 we multiply these numbers as we
are filling the first and the second and
the third slot four times five is twenty
and twenty times five is 100 one hundred
ways is the answer we can form one
hundred three-digit numbers greater than
200 using these five digits when
repetition is allowed do we have to
start with the condition when repetition
is allowed nope when repetition is
allowed we can start off with any of the
slots we will get the same answer